how's it going Rasmus today we're gonna
play just oh no one cares okay I'm gonna
be albino goat I'm gonna be okay
tapas do you want neo flip book quran
forsaken mm-hmm you want the first taken
are you sure
glacial great for you gay this is all
about love and killing each other yeah
mainly killing each other I'm the white
[ __ ]
sorry what I'm deranged so all right so
I have to touch your heart by killing me
why am i breakdancing Sam no no don't
touch it I'm calling it my heart is fun
come in come in how many had ah ah eat
that ass I'm telling you to eat ass
sorry jazz I like jazz I'm stuck now
that's my chance
that's my chance too bad the controls
are impossible
man yeah yeah what are you doing never
okay fine no lay on top of me you fatty
alright we're free come on yeah yeah oh
my heart will go I will get you I will
get you coming hey touch my back
touch it smack it I know that's why it's
what Jimmy come on know what you want
some of it I'm white this is not your
turf that's nice you mean there I'm not
gonna suck you in any way yeah
damn what did I get you I don't know I
got you come on bite me oooh
two strikes come here oh it's like star
holes between our walls in space oh yes
what
dat barrel barrel you seriously call me
that yes I want to kill you so bad
seriously Kenny Kenny hmm
gonna penetrate your heart ah you're not
you will never be a good ballerina as I
am you albino racism mist what's up
Oh use paper piercer heart like Pierce
Brosnan if he was here it would be
enough oh yes
oh just lay there keep playing named I'm
gonna okay now really it was a trap but
I come out I'm riding you know you know
no where am I going
help you're cray-cray yes okay I have
glitter and Southside meet you oh you're
right
yes very good very good what touch it
again all right
it's like the different mode tournament
what are they well well we have balls
watch out for the balls might say watch
out for the there we go that's it all
this trick tomorrow that's the oldest
normal trick in the book no no don't
pierce brosnan me
I hate when you do that come on I'm like
so many balls I never seen this many
balls in my life
now I'm playing like a normal show me
your heart be vulnerable
yeah not in my mouth that's disgusting
stop saying that yeah again no come on
let me pee come here come on let me
anytime
no once fine you know I would like
penetrate me don't eat my heart I'm
letting you do it open for you the balls
are really amazing I know
come on aim for my bike you know come on
No
yeah good job you win a plane what are
you gonna do hmm
the balls are running everything for me
yeah yeah yeah and Mac Mac and for me
[Music]
wait
oh I win everything ever that was almost
a tip that wait just a tap but yeah
they'd like it
roughest they're sensitive